صوره اخرى لمحطه قطارات الشباب التي تعرضت
لحجوم صباح اليوم وهناك كما اشار مراسل
العربيه هناك خمسه جرح هاجر عمليه الطعن
في محطه قطارات الشمال في باريس همم وزير
الداخليه الفرنسيه تحدث عن تحييد منفذ
عمليه الطعن في محطه القطارات وشرطه باريس
تؤكد انها اوقفت منافذ الهجوم على محطه
القطارات وشرطه اطلقت النار ايضا على
منافذ عمليه الطعن ونجحت في تحيده هذه اذا
المشاهدين الصور اوليه من داخل محطه
قطارات الشمال التي تعرضت لهجوم خلال صباح
هذا اليوم وهناك انباء خمسه قتل خمسه جرح
عفوا سقطوا حتى هذه اللحظه همم
الاصابات في عمليه الطعام في محطه الجاردي
نور تسمى محطه كارت دينار في باريس حسين
مدى تاثر حركه القطارات همم في همم باريس
في منطقه الشمال فقط في جميع انحاء باريس
في هذا الوقت الذي يتوقع ان يكون مضطا
باعداد الناس المتوجهين الى اعمالهم
في التوقيت الذي وقع فيه الاعتداء طبعا
تكون هناك كثافه استخدام
لمحطات القطار وايضا لحفلات النقل العام
ومحطات القطار السريع كل هذه المحطات في
كاردينار في المحطه التي وقع فيها
الاعتداء وفي محيط بها
توقفت عن العمل طبعا لسبب الامني الذي
ذكرناه كما ان الشرطه ضرب فوقا امنيه حول
المنطقه التي وقع فيها الاعتداء واتخذت
اجراءات امنيه على طول الطرق المؤديه الى
المكان الذي وقع فيه الاعتداء وردت الان
خبر يؤكد فيه وزير الداخليه
الفرنسي جيرالديرما ان المعتدي تم تحديده
شكر القوى الامنيه على رده فعلها الفعاله
الفاعله والشجاعه ابي حسب تعبيره اكد سقوط
عده جرحه نتيجه الانتهاء الاعتداء الذي
الحسين
القطارات الفرنسيه تتحدث عن عوده الحركه
لطبيعتها في محطه قطرات الشباب في باريس
بعد حادثه الطاعه ماذا نعرف حول ذلك ايضا
دعني اشير الى خبر عاجل او برد
الان يفيد بان المعتدي في طريقه الى
المستشفى هو ينقل الان الى المستشفى بعد
ان اصيب بجراح نتيجه اطلاق الشرطه النار
عليه كما كنت ذكرت لك بعد صيامه باعتداء
بالسلاح الابيض
ومزيد من القوى الامنيه تتوجه الان الى
محطه اطارات الشباب
خمسه اشخاص بجراح
عندما قام المعتدي بتوجيه طعنات اليهم
بالسلاح الابيض فوق امني ضرب حول محطه
قطارات الشمال التي يستخدمها بكثافه الذين
يرغبون في التوجه الى اعمالهم ليس فقط ضمن
باريس
اخرى خصوصا في الشمال تحديدا ليل والمدن
الفرنسيه الواقعه في الشمال من هنا تعود
تسميتها محطه قطارات الشمال هناك خبر ولد
الان يفيد بان خطوط اخرى
محطه القطار تاثرت بما حصل وتوقفت حركتها
اذا حركه النقل العام طلب ليس فقط في ما
حصل في صلاه الشمال وانما في مناطق
الغاوره لها وعندها خطوط المترو مترو
الانفاق والقطارات السريعه وايضا حافله
النقل العام